[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat pour un nouveau numéro
de 100 % Sénat l'émission qui vous fait
vivre les travaux de la Haute Assemblée
les sénateurs de la commission des
affaires étrangères ont auditionné David
Colomb chercheur au Centre d'histoire de
sciencep et auteur du livre intitulé la
guerre de l'information les États à la
conquête de nos esprits ce livre montre
comment les grandes puissances tentent
de contrôler les opinions publiques en
manipulant l'information notamment
depuis le développement d'Internet je
vous laisse écouter cette audition vous
évoquez ces stratégies globales
cohérentes
multidirectionnelles déployé par les
États autoritaires pour affaiblir les
démocraties occidentales vous analysez
notamment les actions de la Russie mais
vous citez aussi et c'est intéressant la
Chine l'Iran et la Corée du Nord
vous pourrez sans doute nous exposer le
lien entre la guerre informationnelle et
les affrontements plus conventionnels y
compris sur les champs de bataille
comment les États autoritaires en
sont-ils venus à développer ces
stratégies quels sont leurs contours et
leur efficacité comment s'en prémunir et
aussi pardon comment répliquer sans
renoncer à notre tour aux libertés
démocratiques c'est probablement la
difficulté de l'exercice enfin vous
pourrez peut-être nous indiquer comment
nos partenaires et alliés répondent à
ces enjeux je pense en particulier pas
seulement mais en particulier aux
États-Unis qui ont compris avant les
autres l'importance du champ
informationnel voilà sans être plus long
monsieur le professeur je vous laisse
présenter votre analyse au cours d'un
propos liminaire et puis nos collègues
de la commission pourront vous
interroger je rappelle que cette
audition est captée et diffusée en
direct sur le site du Sénat je m'en
réjouis car je crois que votre audition
aujourd'hui a aussi un rôle
d'information à l'intention de nos
compatriotes monsieur le professeur Vous
AVEZ LA PAROLE monsieur Président
Mesdames
etessieurs et Messieurs Mesdames et
Messieurs sur le bouton et euh monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs et les sénatrices mesdames et
messieurs je voudrais d'abord vous
remercier pour votre invitation je suis
très heureux de pouvoir venir m'exprimer
devant vous non pour présenter un livre
mais effectivement pour traiter du sujet
de ce livre à savoir la guerre de
l'information qui à mes yeux caractérise
à mes yeux d'historiens caractérise non
seulement les 10 dernières années mais
en réalité la
période qui que nous avons connu depuis
la fin de la guerre froide c'est-à-dire
depuis qu'à l'équilibre de la guerre
froide a
succédé un déséquilibre qui est celui de
la guerre de l'information la guerre
froide était caractérisée par
l'opposition de deux modèles économiques
idéologiqu et par le recours à des
conflits périphériques et à la crainte
du conflit nucléaire la guerre de
l'information se caractérise par des
conflits directs mais en desessà du
seuil de conflictualité ouvert par le
recours à l'information comme à une arme
aussi bien dans l'espace médiatique
traditionnel que dans l'espace
cybernétique le bouleversement introduit
par la fin de la guerre froide en
réalité est en effet lié à l'avèement
des systèmes d'information numérique et
à leur utilisation aussi bien dans un
champ militaire que dans un champ
médiatique et civil il est lié aussi à
l'avènement de médias planétaire à
l'image de CNN il est lié aussi et je
dois le dire pour commencer à une
volonté quelque peu hégémonique des
États-Unis en matière d'information à la
fin de la guerre froide volonté
hégémonique qui s'est traduite en 1991
par le recours à l'information comme à
une arme aussi bien sur le le champ de
bataille pour des opérations
d'information pour des opérations de
cybergerre pour également des opérations
visantes à permettre aux soldats
américains de disposer d'une d'un
contrôle de l'espace informationnel sur
le champ de bataille mais aussi une
domination informationnelle dans le
champ médiatique global pour faire
prévaloir le point de vue des États-Unis
et par la suite cela a conduit à une
évolution très profonde de la doctrine
des États-Unis par exemple avec
l'événement de ce que l'on a appelé
Joseph na a appelé le soft power qui en
est une conséquence directe où l'on
promeut son pays à travers ses valeurs
ses symboles sa culture à travers la
naissance de la cybergerre le mot net à
ce moment-là et traduit à la fois les
actions dans le cyberespace mené par des
pirates informatiques et des soldats
cybergerriers mais aussi la guerre du
net la guerre d'Internet c'est-à-dire la
volonté des États à commencé par les
États-Unis de faire prévaloir leur récit
dans ce nouvel espace d'information et
de communication qui échappe au cadre
traditionnel régulés des médias dans un
régime démocratique comme dans un régime
autoritaire et cette volonté de
domination de l'information a été perçue
on le sait aujourd'hui de façon très
nette par un certain nombre de rég de
régime comme une menace existentielle
cela a été perçu comme une menace
existentielle pour le régime russe qui a
vu certes la disparition de l'URSS et du
Parti communiste mais pas la disparition
des services de renseignement qui depuis
1918 pour le renseignement militaire
russe et depuis 1954 pour le KGB devenu
FSB et SVR ont poursuivi sur la longue
durée une entreprise qui était résumée
par une formule de Rolf wagenbreet
prononcée en 1986 à Dresde dres où un
certain Vladimir Poutine était alors
agent de liaison du KGB auprès de
l'ashtasie il s'agissait d'un travail de
décomposition des sociétés adverses
travail qui se poursuit je vais revenir
dans un instant la menace a été
également perçue comme vital existentiel
par le régime chinois on sait
aujourd'hui que le président Yang Zemin
devant des cadres du renseignement civil
en 1993 a dénoncé je cite la guerre
mondiale sans
qui selon lui était mené par les
États-Unis de la même façon que les
dirigeants du renseignement extérieur
russe voyent la main des États-Unis dans
la chute de
l'URSS les dirigeants de Pékin voyaient
la main des États-Unis dans les
événements du Printemps de Pékin et
voyit dans l'essort des médias
planétaires une menace pour la stabilité
de leur régime ce qui a conduit ces
régimes autoritaire et d'autres que vous
avez cité monsieur le Président l'Iran
la Corée du Nord a adopté des mesures de
protection de leur espace informationnel
à l'égard d'un gérance étrangère on
interdit les antennes satellites on
interdit les médias étrangers on
contrôle l'information qui circule à
destination de ces citoyens mais cela
les a conduit également à se doter de
ces nouveaux attributs de la puissance à
l'ère informationnelle que sont le soft
power la Chine a été le premier pays au
monde à se réapproprier le soft power
sous le nom de Ruan Chili en 198
3 la Russie l'a fait par la voix de
Vladimir Poutine c'est la Makaya Sila je
crois pardonnez-m russe en 2013 ils se
sont dotés aussi d'équipe de ha cœur de
cybergerriers pour faire face à la
menace que représentaient à leurs yeux
les équipes de cybergerriers de la NSA
et des actions offensives ils se sont
dotés vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président de médias internationaux pour
dans un premier temps porter leur voix
sur la scène internation nationale et
dans un second temps affaiblir la voie
de nos démocraties et fragiliser nos
démocraties de l'intérieur et depuis
l'avénement des téléphones portables
depuis l'avénement des réseaux sociaux
ils ont perçu la menace comme
particulièrement accentué je crois que
le tournant majeur en ce qui concerne la
Russie se situe en décembre 2011 lorsque
à la suite des printemps arabes souvent
qualifiés de révolution Twitter ou de
révolution de Z0 le président euh pardon
le Premier ministre Vladimir Poutine a
perçu dans les manifestations moscovit
la main de la CIA a considéré que les
États-Unis avaient l'intention de
recourir à l'information numérique sur
les réseaux sociaux qui étaient alors
tout à fait nouveaux pour renverser son
pouvoir provoquer un changement de
régime et il craignait plusieurs sources
la teste de finir aussi tragiquement
qu'à fini ses jours monsieur Kaddafi ce
qui en retour a conduit dans les années
qui ont suivi une militarisation des
espaces informationnels numérique
c'est-à-dire la transformation en armes
de ce qui étai des outils d'information
et qui étaient perçus par ces régimes
autoritaire comme une menace pour la
stabilité de leur régime il en va de
même pour le président sjinping
lorsqu'il accède au pouvoir au lendemain
de l'essort sur les médias sociaux aux
Chinois d'une contestation inédite dans
l'histoire de la Chine à la suite du
tremblement de terre du Schang
contestation des dirigeants des
fonctionnaires contestation du régime
politique qui a conduit en retour à
l'adoption par la Chine de mesures de
contrôle de son espace informationnel
qui sont en tout point comparables aux
mesures prises par la Russie vous savez
Charles Py Charles pegy disait il faut
dire ce que l'on voit surtout il faut
toujours ce qui est plus difficile voir
ce que l'on voit beaucoup de choses ont
été vues mais beaucoup ont refusé de
voir ce qu'ils voyaent parce que voulait
voir au contraire dans les échanges avec
ces régimes autoritaires dans le
discours porté par certains dirigeants
de ces régimes autoritaires une promesse
de changement une promesse de
démocratisation je cite dans mon livre
ce discours de Bill Clinton à
l'Université de Pékin en 1998 qui
aujourd'hui apparaît d'une
extraordinaire naïveté lorsque devant
les dirigeants du Parti communiste il
explique qu'après 4 jours de visite des
villages en Chine il avait vu
l'information circulait librement il
avait vu les téléphones portables
permettre à des villageois de
s'organiser de se doter de leur propre
syndicat de se doter de leur propre
système électoral de procéder eux-mêmes
à leur li à leurs élections il avait vu
un vent de liberté sur la Chine et au
retour dans l'avion il glisse à
l'oreille du correspondant du New York
Times qui l'accompagnait qu'il était
convaincu que ce que les américain
appelle le free flow of information la
libre circulation de l'information all
les conduire à l'effondrement du Parti
communiste chinois et ce à quoi nous
assistons aujourd'hui c'est non
seulement au fait que le Parti
communiste chinois ne s'est pas effondré
mais que le Parti communiste chinois
c'est en l'espace de 20 ans depuis
l'adoption par l'Armée populaire de
libération de la doctrine dite des trois
guerres doté du plus grand appareil de
renseignement au monde plus grand
appareil de renseignement de l'histoire
il s'est doté de la plus grande cyber
armée au monde il s'est doté des plus
grandes équipes de cyber mercenaires il
s'est doté d'outil stratégique lui
permettant de porter sa supériorité
informationnelle par-delà ses frontières
il s'est doté d'outils de communication
que non pas d'autres régimes
autoritaires la Russie de Vladimir
Poutine a pu instrumentaliser comme je
le raconte les systèmes publicitaires de
Facebook pour semer le chaos aux
États-Unis et interf fér avec les
élections mais le crremelin ne dispose
pas n'a jamais disposé de l'équivalent
de ktok qui est aujourd'hui une arme
redoutable entre les mains d'un régime
autoritaire qui peut interférer
directement avec le cerveau de milliards
de personnes sur la planète au profit de
ses ambitions
géostratégiques je ne vais pas vous
mentir mon anxiété était grande en
écrivant ce livre et je n'ai je ne
prends aucun plaisir à exprimer de l'an
ni à transmettre de l'anxiété mais j'ai
pour habitude de chercher à voir ce que
je vois et à le présenter au au plus
grand nombre à charge pour ce plus grand
nombre de prendre conscience et surtout
de réagir de la façon appropriée j'ai
conscience que nos adversaires ont une
stratégie de très long terme qui est une
stratégie je le disais tout à l'heure de
décomposition il s'agit de décomposer la
société adverse en affaibl ce qui fait
sa cohésion ce qui fait notre cohésion
dans une société démocratique c'est
d'abord la confiance dans nos
institutions la confiance dans notre
personnel politique la confiance dans
nos institutions dans notre personnel
administratif la confiance dans nos
médias la confiance quant à
l'information à la crédibilité à la
valeur de l'information qui nous
parvient et c'est précisément tout cela
qui est visé depuis longtemps par ces
services de renseignement qui sur la
durée font le même travail qu'il faisait
autrefois mais avec des outils nouveaux
vous savez quand vous regardez le
Conseil de sécurité restreint de la
Fédération de Russie ils sont une petite
dizaine et cinq au moins parmi eux sont
des anciens du KGB qui comme Vladimir
Poutine sont entrés au KGB dans les
années
1970 qui comme lui pour beaucoup sont
passés par le premier directorat
c'est-à-dire le renseignement extérieur
du KGB qui pour beaucoup comme Poutine
ont été formés de mains de maître à
l'art de la manipulation de la
subversion et de la propagande par yri
Andropov qui avait coutume de dire que
la meilleure des informations était
celle qui trouvait ses propres relais
que l'on avait pas besoin de soutenir à
bout de bras qui prenaent prise dans un
environnement donné et trouvait des
élateurs qui volontairement allaiit
amplifier son contenu et conduire à ce
que andropof et les autres appelit un
virus médiatique et ce que les Russes
désormais enfin les stratèges russes de
la désinformation coutume d'appeler un
virus psychologique qui à la manière
d'un virus humain a besoin d'un autre il
se transmet d'humain en humain qui à la
manière d'un virus s'il n'est pas
détecté par un test peut infecter un
grand nombre de personne avant que l'on
constate les effets produits par ce
virus qui peut se répliquer de lui-même
mais là non pas d'humain à humain mais
d'esprit à esprit par de là les océan
par-delà les frontières grâce aux outils
numériques qui permettent une
amplification démesurée les
épidémologistes se penchaient sur le R0
et se penchent encore sur le R0 on peut
contaminer 10 15 personnes un virus
informationnel peut en contaminer 256 à
la fois sur snapchat en 2016 et ces 256
vont en infecter 256 qui vont rapidement
devenir des millions nous avons à faire
à quelque chose qui croit cette ce virus
de la désinformation parce que notre
système immunitaire a été
systématiquement ciblé par les
adversaires de nos démocratie qui en
fragilisant la distinction entre le vrai
et le faux la crédibilité de ceux qui
ont pour fonction d'établir ce qui est
vrai et ce qui est faux ont favorisé la
croyance en des théories parfois
absurdes quand on songe qu'il y a
aujourd'hui 7 millions de personnes au
moins aux États-Unis qui affirment que
la terre est plate et pire encore il y
en a 23 millions qui a la question la
terre est telle ronde répondre je ne
sais pas nous sommes en présence de la
déstabilisation profonde non seulement
des fondement de notre cohésion sociale
à travers l'instrumentalisation du chaos
l'exploitation de toutes les failles de
nos sociétés les ingérences électorales
la guerre psychologique la guerre
cognitive mais nous sommes confrontés au
pire danger qui soit qui est
l'affaiblissement de notre régime de
vérité je voudrais pour terminer cette
introduction trop longue et je vous prie
de m'en excuser citer un autre auteur
qui m'est cher qui est Marc bloc qui
dans l'étrange défaite revenait sur la
responsabilité des médias français dans
la défaite et dans l'esprit de défaite
qui avait pu gagner nos concitoyens en
1940 il s'interrogeait en particulier
sur les influences étrangères fasciste
nazi soviétique notre presse était
perméable à C ses influences étrangères
et il se demandait ce que nous avions
fait pour donner à ce peuple français ce
je cite minimum de renseignements nets
et sûrs sans lequel aucune conduite
rationnelle n'est possible ce qui est
aujourd'hui visé fondamentalement et sur
la longue durée par nos adversaires les
régimes autoritaires qui veulent faire
s'effondrer un certain nombre de nos
régimes démocratiques c'est ce que
Michel fouo appelait le régime de vérité
ce régime qui permet l'énonciation
de fait partagés qui permet la
distinction entre le vrai et le faux et
qui permet surtout à nos concitoyens et
nos concitoyenes d'avoir seulement la
possibilité d'avoir une conduite
rationnelle et ce que nous devons je
crois collectivement défendre
aujourd'hui c'est cette capacité pour
nos concitoyens de disposer d'une
information intègre nette sûre qui
garantisse une conduite rationnelle dans
le respect vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président de ce qui fonde à la fois la
faiblesse intrinsèque et la force de nos
démocratie à savoir le fait que nous
sommes des sociétés ouvertes que nous
sommes des sociétés de liberté liberté
d'expression liberté de réunion liberté
d'association liberté d'informer liberté
d'opinion et que toute atteinte à ses
libertés au nom de la lutte contre les
manipulations de l'information n'a pour
effet que de conforter le scepticisme et
la défiance de ceux qui en souffr déjà
et de conforter le discours de nos
adversaires qui ont beau jeu alors de
comparer notre attitude à la propre
attitude qui est la leure à l'égard par
exemple de leurs opposants ou de leur
minorité je conclus le livre par ces
mots d'un poète allemand Fredrich Erlin
là où croit le péril croit aussi ce qui
sauve je suis convaincu que la prise de
conscience dont cette audition est à mes
yeux l'expression et le plus sûr moyen
pour nos démocraties de faire face aux
enjeux de l'année 2024 qui sera une
année difficile pour nous tous merci
beaucoup merci à vous pour ces propos
préliminaires on va rentrer dans la
phase questionsréponse j'ai quatre
demandes de parole mais il peut y en
avoir d'autres euh je vous propose que
on fasse questionréponse une question
une réponse au au fil de l'eau première
question c'est François
bonau merci
président merci merci Monsieur pour la
clarté de vos propos sur les les menaces
virales du monde
euh avec plus de 200 millions
d'utilisateurs actifs chat GPT c'est
c'est imposé comme un acteur de de masse
dans dans l'a convers conversationnel
pardon on peut considérer que quiicte
prendrait le contrôle de l'architecture
neuronal de cette intelligence
artificielle pourrait orienter les les
réponses produites à des fins politiques
voire idéologiques certains chercheurs
recommande d'investir massivement dans
les technologies de reconnaissance
stylométrique et de tournure
linguistique redondante à afin de
détecter les productions pures de
l'intelligence artificielle quels sont
selon vous les outils adéquates pour
encadrer l'utilisation de l'intelligence
artificielle afin d'en préserver les
bienfaits tout en bannissant les les
pratiques
malveillantes bien évidemment très
réel merci pour votre question
effectivement c'est un enjeu essentiel
que celui de l'intelligence artificielle
qui est un enjeu qui ne se limite pas à
la génération de faux contenus qui est
ce qui qui intéresse le plus la
discussion publique actuellement mais il
y a beaucoup de choses que l'on ne voit
pas aisément qui sont beaucoup plus
dommageables à nos démocrati notamment
le recours à des outils d'intelligence
artificielle pour détecter
automatiquement des failles dans nos
systèmes d'information des failles
qu'exploitent par exemple des pirates
informatiques pour perturber le
fonctionnement de système adverse et le
gardien a a révélé il y a de jours la
pénétration de de système d'une centrale
nucléaire britannique par des hackurs
agit
pour la Chine et la Russie ces
détections des failles ne se limitent
pas au
système structurel mais également aux
failles de nos esprits et l'une des
particularités de l'intelligence
artificielle telle qu'elle est utilisée
aujourd'hui d'ors et déjà par les
plateformes numériques quelles qu'elles
soi et l'exploitation de l'analyse
prédictive de la personnalité à des fins
de microciiblage publicitaire et parfois
d'exploitation subversives des failles
de nos esprits par certains acteurs
malveillants pour produire des effets
parfois dommageables pour nos sociétés
il y a enfin cette question de la
génération de faux contenus qui pose un
problème systémique dans la mesure où
les progrès de l'intelligence
artificielle sont des progrès
exponentiels qui nécessairement devrait
conduire prochainement à une situation
fort désagréable dans laquelle le faux
primera quantitativement sur le vrai
dans l'environnement informationnel ce
qui aura des effets en retour tous les
systèmes par exemple les systèmes de
moteur de recherche qui reposent sur une
approche inductive c'est-à-dire
statistiquement détermine le vrai en
fonction de ce l'information qui domine
la terre est ronde parce que la plupart
des gens sur Internet affirment qu'elle
est ronde si un
jour l'information selon laquelle elle
est plate domine un système de ce type
pourrait à une question posée par un
utilisateur répondre bien sûr la terre
plat pu autrement dit c'est ce problème
est systémique
je crains pour ma part que toute
approches autorégulatrice soit vouée à
l'échec comme ont été voué à l'échec les
approches autorégulatrices engagées par
la Commission européenne à l'égard de la
diffusion de la désinformation sur les
plateformes numérique en décembre
2018 je constate que l'approche
règlement du DSA là où elle a été
implémentée ne donne pas les résultats
escomptés et ne peut pas apporter de
réponse en temps réel au dangers
représentés par la menace dans la mesure
où tous les chercheurs en matière de
désinformation s'accordent à dire que
l'information la désinformation a
produit ses effets lorsqu'elle a été
diffusée vous pouvez ensuite démentir
une fausse information elle laissera des
traces vous pouvez chercher à démentir
une fausse information auprès de gens
qui pensent que la terre est plate vous
les conforterez dans l'idée que la terre
est plate parce qu'ils considéreront que
c'est louche si vous cherchez à les
convaincre du contraire autrement dit
j'ai pour ma part une autre approche qui
consiste à envisager plutôt de
privilégier un espace intègre en matière
informationnelle dans le domaine
numérique pourquoi ne pas considérer un
espace dans lequel pourrai interagir des
internautes sans modèles publicitaires
qui exploiteraient leur le leur
fragilité psychique et donneraiit prise
à des influenceurs notamment étrangers
malveillants pourquoi ne pas envisager
un système qui ne permettrait pas non
plus l'amplification artificielle des
contenus ni le recours à l'intelligence
artificielle autrement dit un système
proprement humain
d'information qui offrirait des
garanties d'intégrité pour ces des
utilisateurs il me semble que c'est une
voie qui a trop peu été envisagée et qui
n'est pas la moins difficile à mettre en
œuvre si l'on consère les possibilités
techniques de certaines plateformes
comme blue sky qui sont des plateformes
décentralisées qui pourrai par
exemple si la Commission européenne
s'orientait dans cette direction
permettre à tous les utilisateurs
européens de bénéficier d'un espace
intgre respectueux en soi par définition
des règlements européens en vigueur et
qui ne poseraiit pas les mêmes risques
systémiques pardon pour cette réponse
très longue merci pour la réponse la
parole est à Roger
carucci
professeur bon les ingérances étrangères
c'est vieux comme le
monde en 1914 Benito Mussolini qui
possédait un journal en Italie Popolo
d'Italia recevit de l'argent des
services secrets français et anglais
pour pousser l'Itali à rentr en guerre
dans de guerre l'œuvre française je suis
partout oui recevez de l'argent des
nazis et des fascistes italiens pour
faire justement la propagande de de ces
pays et d'un changement de politique
française donc c'est pas
récent soyons franc après la Deuxième
Guerre mondiale les Soviétiques d'un
côté la CIA de l'autre côté ont financé
des syndicats des journaux en France et
ailleurs donc c'est pas nouveau je dire
l'ingérance étrang
c'est un élément de politique étrangère
depuis des siècles je dirais pres que
depuis des millénaires j'ai quelques
souvenirs dans mes études d'avoir vu que
Athène ne se privait pas de payer
certains services à spart donc c'est pas
nouveau mais ce qui a changer c'est le
contact direct c'est
qu'avec le système des réseaux en
réalité on ne peut plus trouver un
responsable
nos services d'enquête ne peuvent plus
annoncer qu'on met en examen tel ou tel
parce qu'il a reçu de l'argent des
services
étrangers maintenant le service étranger
a un accès direct à des millions de
personnes en même temps et là on ne sait
plus trop comment réagir alors vous avez
raison le premier élément c'est
probablement
que les citoyens retrouvent trou
confiance
ou crédit dans la parole publique dans
leur propre pays ou dans leurs médias
dans leur propre pays parce que dès
qu'ils n'ont plus
confiance forcément l'ingérence
étrangère est plus forte et en tout cas
elle a plus
d'impact mais alors j'entends bien ce
que vous dites sur pourquoi ne pas
développer secteur intègre sans
publicité c'est probablement une arme
claire mais est-ce que nos gouvernants
ne sont pas
en réalité aussi coupable de ne pas être
capable de défendre la démocratie euh
avec mon cher
collègue nous nous allons
présenter le budget qu'on apprécie qu'on
approuve enfin qu'on apprécie pas mais
qu'on approuve sur les médias extérieurs
de la France on est extrêmement rêveur
naïf on met 3 francs 6 sous de crédit
sur notre nos médias extérieurs alors
que on se fait promener en Afrique on se
fait promener au Proche Orient on se
fait promener partout et on continue de
penser qu'avec trois machins on va on va
trouver la solution il est clair que
face aux dictatures ou face aux régimes
autoritaire que je refuse d'appeler le
je sais pas quoi le sud global
appellation Kedor c'est stupide s'il en
est devant l'éternel mais enfin bon
laissons cela mais est-ce que parce que
vous vous parlez de l'IMP importance de
l'ingérence étrangère parce que c'est
pas d'abord la
faiblesse de notre réaction de nos
régimes la démocratie ça ne se défend
pas que par la parole est-ce que
là-dessus on ne devrait pas être plus
plus fort
dans la présence de de médias extérieurs
qu'il soit d'ailleurs français
britannique américains c'estàd est-ce
que les pays démocratiques ne sont pas
faibles face à des offensives chinoises
russes ou autres euh dans dans le
domaine des médias avant même de l'être
dans le domaine de
l'Internet professeur à vous merci
monsieur le sénateur pour votre question
la la force de notre société ce sont ces
valeurs et ce sont ces valeurs que nous
devons défendre pour rester
attrayant dans le monde
euh vous avez tout à fait raison de
souligner que l'influence étrangère
n'est pas nouvelle et que ce qui est
nouveau c'est
sa portée qui est sans commune mesure
avec ce qui a été connu jusqu'à présent
en ce qui concerne les moyens que l'on
peut mettre en œuvre il me semble que le
premier à mettre en œuvre est la
transparence nous avons besoin de mettre
en évidence aux yeux du plus grand
nombre la réalité de ces ingérences
étrangères euh pour cela une proposition
qui a été je crois faite par l'un de nos
services de renseignement et qui me
paraît
parfaitement judicieuse c'est l'adoption
d'une loi comparable à celle qui existe
depuis 1938 aux États-Unis et qui fait
obligation à quiconque mène une action
d'influence à l'intérieur de notre
territoire pour le compte d'un agent
étranger étatique ou non étatique de
déclarer son activité il ne s'agit pas
d'une loi liberticide comme l'est la loi
sur les agents étrangers
du cremelin qui une fois que quelqu'un
est qualifié d'agent étranger lui
vaut les pires choses là il s'agit d'une
loi de
transparence pour rendre visible au plus
grand nombre ce qui se passe en matière
d'ingérence quantifier l'ingérence des
différents pays autoritaires comme non
autoritaire du reste quant à leur
volonté de faire prévaloir un certain
nombre de récits il y a tentation de
certains pays par exle exemple de
fragiliser le soutien de notre opinion
publique envers le rayonnement de la
France en Afrique et dans l'océan Indien
cela doit être rendu visible au plus
grand nombre pour que la société s'en
empare et que ce ne soit pas le monopole
de nos services voués à la défense et la
protection de notre souveraineté en même
temps parmi ces services il me semble
que il est aujourd'hui plus que
nécessaire de renforcer et de doté plus
considérablement ceux qui sont en
première ligne de cette guerre de
l'information et qui ont fait la preuve
de leur efficacité je pense en premier
lieu bien évidemment à viginum je pense
en premier lieu à la sous-direction du
kedorset en charge de ces questions
stratégiques de la veille et de la
ripost ils sont de mon point de vue de
chercheur sous-doté sous-équipé cont
tenu de la menace et à la veille d'une
une année électorale et à la veille
d'une année marquée par les Jeux
Olympiques qui vont être un peu le sur
le super marché mondial de l'ingérence
et de la déstabilisation euh il est plus
qu'urgent aujourd'hui de leur donner les
moyens de faire face à cette menace
enfin euh s'agissant de nos médias de
service publics il est bon de rappeler
qu'ils sont des médias de services
publics et non des médias d'État
qu'ils ne sont pas aux ordres du pouvoir
exécutif et ne sont pas là pour porter
la voix de tel ou tel membre de
l'exécutif mais de porter la voix de
l'intérêt général bien évidemment aussi
la voix de la France mais sans recourir
à la manipulation comme le font d'autres
médias qui sont des médias
d'État et dont les rédacteurs en chef
sonorent eux-mêmes publiquement d'être
je les cite des guerriers de
l'information le doigt sur la couture du
pantalon pour obéir aux ordres de leurs
autorités politiques il faut investir
dans le journalisme de qualité vous
savez je vois aussi dans nos médias
internationaux des journalistes
extraordinairement valeureux qui font
face à des campagnes de déstabilisation
qui parfois les visent eux-mêmes qui
sont d'une brutalité inouï qui font face
à une croissance exponentielle de la
désinformation avec peu de moyens ils
ont besoin aujourd'hui d'être aidé et
puis nous avons besoin de renforcer
l'immunité de notre société face à ces
ingérences par le renforcement du
journalisme de qualité ce que j'appelle
le journalisme de qualité c'est le
journalisme qui répond à une à une
démarche déontologique et éthique qui
s'engage à suivre cette démarche et qui
par exemple dans le cadre actuel de ce
qui existe adhère à la démarche de
reporter sans frontière qui s'appelle
GTI journalism trust initiative et qui
voit ses journaux s'engager à respecter
ses règles déontologiques accepter un
audit extérieur pour pour vérifier
qu'ils assurent bien cela et nous
pourrions envisager de réorienter une
partie des aides publ à la presse en
priorité vers ce journalisme de qualité
nous pourrions envisager de contraindre
les plateformes numériques à amplifier
la portée de ce journalisme de qualité
il ne s'agit pas de stigmatiser l'autre
journalisme il s'agit
d'encourager ce journalisme de qualité
et potentiellement de confiance pardon
encore une fois pour cette réponse très
longue Olivier Cadic
oui merci beaucoup effectivement très
très
intéressant nous avons reçu un
spécialiste de l'OTAN qui nous a qui
combat les trolls et qui nous a montré
que en fait le temps moyen pour lire une
news et de 7 secondes donc effectivement
les technologies de la de manipulation
ne sont pas nouvelles comme l'a dit
notre collègue mais surtout le vrai le
faux tout dépend l'idée qu'on s'en fait
et chacun a sa vérité apparaît le
concept de vérité alternative donc en
fait l'objet c'est de créer la confusion
dans les esprits c'est ça que cherche à
faire en fait les les les Russes souvent
et vous avez raison une fake news est
réussie à partir du moment où elle est
disséminée et j'is quand même que le
mariage du buounti au Mali a été quand
même le plus grand cas d'école
puisqueaujourd'hui encore vous tapez sur
les réseaux sociaux et vous allez tout
sur les moteur de recherche et vous
allez voir ça comme un fait avéré alors
que personne n'a jamais vu une photo du
mariage ni des mariés donc on sait même
pas de quoi il s'agit mais toujours
est-il que ça a fait son effet ce qui me
gêne un petit peu enfin ce que je je
comprends j'apprécie tous vos propos
mais mais j'ai l'impression que en fait
tout n'est que défensif dans ce qui dans
dans la réaction euh qu'on devrait avoir
en disant on va on va donner une
information de qualité essayer de la la
rendre intègre mais tout ça en fait
c'est une réaction par rapport à ce qui
nous
arrive
Taïwan travaille cette question
fortement d'ailleurs ils ont développé
tout un un modèle de réponse donc
faisant en sorte que la communauté
justement la collectivité soit participe
à la réaction avec des réponses à une
fake news en 2h en utilisant le l'humour
mais tout ça n'est que de la défense
est-ce que vous trouvez pas que
Prigogine en fait quelque part nous a
montré la voie pour
déstabiliser la Russie est-ce que quels
sont les points faibles de la Chine et
de la Russie pour le pour sur lesqueles
nous pourrions travailler et être de
notre côté un petit peu offensif
merci merci monsieur le sénateur pour
votre question j'insiste sur l'aspect
défensif dans la mesure où je sais que
l'aspect offensif ça a fait l'objet
d'investissement important depuis
longtemps il y a longtemps que nos
armées ont pris conscience de la menace
de la propagande
djihadiste que l'amiral coustillère a
constitué une
équipe et a mené des actions de
contred-iscours la France est dotée d'un
d'un come cyberè qui est un modèle
international de ce qui peut-être fait
pour porter le combat au-delà de nos
frontières mais vous aurez compris que
si je je n'évoque pas l'aspect offensif
c'est parce que ma priorité en tant que
chercheur et auteur de ce
livre c'est de
préserver la sérénité de dosb
démocratique de préserver notre
démocratie de préserver nos libertés
face à des ingérences
étrangères auxqueles on n'oppose pas
toujours une réponse adaptée je vais
vous parler comme je crois le faire sans
langue de bois vous citz Taïwan
l'approche de Taiwan est une approche
horizontale c'est-à-dire que l'ensemble
de la société pour commencer est
consciente de la menace l'ensemble de la
société a accès à des informations
factuelles sur l'état de la menace
l'ensemble de la société est éduqué non
pas au médias de façon générale mais à
la désinformation comment la détecter et
comment s'en prémunir l'ensemble de la
société est mobilisé dans une démarche
qui relève de ce que j'appelle dans le
livre La Défense
informationnelle en France nous avons
une approche en silo une approche en
tuyau d'org nous avons des services qui
ne collaborent pas toujours suffisamment
entre eux et nous avons une tendance
assez lourde à privilégier le secret
pour tout ce qui qui relève des
questions dont nous traitons ce matin et
cette tendance nous est préjudiciable
dans la mesure où souvent elle nous
conduit à ne pas appréhender les
opérations d'ingérance à l'échelle qui
est la leure permettez-moi de donner un
exemple récent ces moldaves qui ont
dessiné sur les murs des étoiles de
David vous avez d'un côté le volet
judiciaire et sécuritaire vous avez de
l'autre le volet de l'amplification
officiel sur Twitter pour porter cela à
la connaissance des journalistes vous
avez ensuite le volet médiatique avec
l'absence de formation des journalistes
à ce type d'opération de déstabilisation
dont ils sont couramment la cible et
tout ça est traité de façon
dispersée monsieur le Président tout à
l'heure vous évoquiez ce que les
États-Unis ont ont fait la principale
réalisation des États-Unis a été en la
matière le jack le Global engagement
Center le centre d'engagement global
comme son nom l'indique il appréhende la
menace à l'échelle globale c'est-à-dire
que il unit des personnels du Pentagone
donc des militaires à des personnels
civils du Département d'État à des
personnels de la communauté du
renseignement c'estd 15 services de
renseignement principaux des États-Unis
aux représentants des médias
internationaux qui sont associés à la
discussion à un écosystème de chercheurs
un écosystème d'industriel qui aussi
prennent part à cette dimension et nous
avons besoin d'une même approche globale
enfin permettez-moi une dernière
remarque puisque j'ai j'ai été invité
par le com cyber à m'exprimer récemment
à Rennes à l'occasion de la cyber week
et j'ai fait le tour de notre
industrie en matière de cyberdéfense
j'ai fait je ne citerai aucune industrie
aucun industriel mais j'ai été frappé
par le fait que nous disposons vraiment
d'industriel remarquabl qui propose tout
ce qu'il faut en matière de défense de
nos systèmes d'information vraiment la
France est un pays leader dans le monde
en matière de cybécurité nous avons une
industrie remarquable que proposent ces
industriels en matière de de de pour
pour pour la dernière faille de sécurité
qui se situe entre la chaise et
l'ordinateur c'est-à-dire l'être humain
qui va cliquer sur le lien sur lequel il
ne va pas il devrait pas cliquer l'être
humain qui va relayer le l'information
qu'il ne devrait pas relayer l'être
humain qui recevant une information va
réagir par un acte de colère et dans
certains cas passer à l'acte un acte
délictuel ou criminel à l'heure actuelle
nous ne proposons rien et c'est la
raison pour laquelle il me paraît
aujourd'hui plus que jamais nécessaire
d'engager une démarche de défense
informationnelle pour sensibiliser nos
concitoyens à la menace les doter des
outils de percevoir la menace de voir ce
qu'il voit d'agir en conséquence doter
aussi nos services et notre armée des
moyens d'établir des liens
consubstantiel non seulement avec les
industries de défense mais avec tous les
citoyens et tous les citoyennes qui sont
préoccupés par ces questions et adopter
cette démarche défensive qui nous
permettra d'affronter la menace qui se
présente devant nous et qui ne va pas
malheureusement dans un temps prochain
décroître je suis encore une fois désolé
de vous répondre si longuement
merci beaucoup Monsieur le Professeur
euh je crois que votre livre est un
livre de salubrité publique un livre
trop rare d'ailleurs
euh et je suis bien entendu entièrement
d'accord avec vous je voudrais peut-être
faire quelques remarques la première
c'est que euh vous datez il faut
toujours dater les les les les études
que l'on fait de d'un certain moment euh
vous le datez de la fin de la période de
la guerre froide je remonterai pas
jusqu'à spart et athè comme Roger kouci
le faisait tout à l'heure mais je dirais
que nous avons un retard d'un siècle en
fait nous n'avons pas seulement un
retard de quelques décennies nous avons
un retard d'un
siècle ce
sujet le sujet de la désinformation le
sujet de l'infiltration le sujet des 5è
colonnes Rogel y a fait allusion tout à
l'heure il a commencé en 197 avec la
création de la Teka et du NKVD et nous
avons eu des périodes et je suis
d'accord avec lui là-dessus
peut-être encore plus difficile et plus
dangereuse et et et la première de ces
de de de comment dire de ces de ces
tentatives c'était la tentative la plus
qui a duré presque un siècle qui a duré
70 ans c'était les partis la création
des partis communistes nous avons vécu
dans les socimoces et particulièrement
en France et en Europe avec le principal
outil de désinformation qui étaient les
partis communistes et qui étaient
largement d'une nuisance aussi grande
que celle des réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui nous avons vécu avec le
Mouvement de la Paix qui a désarmé qui a
notamment désarmé la France mais qui a
désarmé beaucoup de de démocratie euh je
je cite une anecdote dans les années 80
quand cétais président de saontière on
travaillait avec Solidar nusk nous avons
nous nous a révélé ce que d'ailleurs la
direction du Figaro savait que le
correspondant du Figaro à Varsovie et
que le correspondant du Figaro à Moscou
étai des agents du du du KGB et que le
Figaro trouvait ça très bien parce que
ça leur permettait d'avoir des
renseignements de première main euh mais
c'est c'est c'était c'était déjà comme
ça à cette échelle alors une première
une et d'ailleurs la deuxème période
difficile je vous rappelle que Revel
écrivait à la fin des années 70 en 1980
comment les démocraties finissent
c'était l'époque de Carter des otages
américains en Iran c'était l'époque où
les Russes Soviétiques étaient en
Afghanistan en étaient en train de en
héritrée Éthiopie aujourd'hui on dit le
Mali Niger et cetera il sétait déjà en
train de conquérir une bonne partie de
l'Afrique et de nous en et de nous en
chasser ou de chasser les les
Occidentaux euh comment ça s'est terminé
ça s'est pas terminé parce qu'on a gagné
la guerre de l'information cette guerre
ou la guerre des des des renseignements
le bouquin de Robert little la compagnie
et probablement moi je le recommande à
tout le monde ici à ceux qui l'ont pas
lu c'est l'histoire de la guerre entre
la CIA et le KGB sur le plan de
l'information et dur ranceignement le
KGB l'a gagné cette guerre et et et de
très loin euh comment elle s'est terminé
elle s'est terminé parce qu'un
jour contre tous les courants un homme a
eu la volonté un homme qu'on présente
ici et notamment en Europe comme un
semiemeurer qui a été un des plus grands
présidents des États-Unis en définitive
a décidé que on allait en terminé par la
volonté politique et après Carter Rean
est arrivé qui c'est c'est Rean qui a
mis l'URSS à genoux et qui a entraîné la
par la guerre des étoiles la fin de
l'URSS c'est donc pas un problème de
renseignement c'est un problème de
volonté politique que évidemment nous
n'avons pas aujourd'hui évidemment
évidemment alors ça ça m'amène à ma à ma
deuxième remarque c'est celle sur la
naïveté j'ai demandé ici au Sénat en
2018 à Cédric ha
euh à l'époque ministre chargé du
numérique l'interdiction de RT et de
Sputnik je me suis fait renvoyer dans
mes buts certains s'en souviennent
peut-être au nom de la liberté
d'expression j'aiexliquais quet qui
était évidemment pas des médias que
c'est c'était fabriqué directement au
directorat d du FSB euh que bon je je je
je je vais pas plus loin et que
évidemment il était de salut public
d'interdire ces ces non médias ces ces
ces chaînes de désinformation et euh je
cdrico a a été offusqué en disant mais
enfin mon gouvernement ne va pas ne va
pas faire une telle atteinte à la
liberté d'expression le 27 février 2022
du jour au lendemain on s'est aperçu
qu'il y av plus de problème de liberté
d'expression la naïveté les démocraties
c'est ça le problème elles réagissent
parfois d'ailleurs jusqu'à présent elles
ont gagné mais elles réagissent tard et
cette naïveté continue cette naïveté
continue euh 3isème remarque le plus
grand danger c'est pas celui à mon avis
de la de de de l'influence extérieure
c'est celui de la menace qui vient de
l'intérieur euh cette menace je parle
pas d'une menace sur le plan de de la
désinformation mais Obama disait les
réseaux sociaux disait dans atlantique
il y a pas très longtemps les réseaux
sociaux sont devenus la principale
menace contre nos démocratie les réseaux
sociaux par abrutissement par leur par
l'ensemble de de de ce qu'il représ je
je pas la peine de faire de dessin ici
tout le monde le sait et il était pas le
seul à dire obamaing ping il y a
quelques mois disait un un a au page de
de de chef d'entreprise mais vous êtes
en train avec vos réseaux sociaux nous
nous les cont parlait pas de censure
bien sûr il y a la censure des réseaux
sociaux en Chine mais il y a aussi des
choses euh assez intelligente que nous
ne faisons pas qui ont pas de la censure
c'est le contrôle de l'utilisation des
des ne serait-ce que des horaires des
réseaux sociaux pour les enfants et ping
expliqué vous êtes en train de détruire
une génération qui ne qui ne fait plus
rien en classe qui ne dort pas la nuit
parce qu'elle regarde les réseaux
sociaux et cetera nous nous les
empêchons de nous avons nous leur
donnons une des horaires pour les
regarder et cetera et cetera nous les
protégeons euh nous ne faisons rien de
cela je voudrais euh faire une dernière
remarque Michel valallley qui est là et
moi-même avons fait récemment rendu un
rapport sur TikTok le rapport s'appelle
la tactique TikTok
opacité addiction et ombre chinoise et
nous terminons ce rapport en disant il y
a des mesures de de santé publique à
prendre des mesure de salubrité publique
qui est le contrôle de l'âge qui est le
contrôle de la modération et cetera et
nous sommes allés voir le ministre du
numérique qui nous a dit oui oui oui il
y a pas de problème bien entendu vous
avez raison et on va faire ça et cetera
et puis d'ailleurs je prépare une grande
loi sur le numérique et l'adaptation du
DSA l'adaptation du DSA en France et moi
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce que
dit Thierry Breton sur le DSA et c'était
un espoir le DSA le DSA est paru il
donnait jusqu'au mois d'août aux
plateformes pour se mettre en conformité
avec toutes les recommandation la
recommandation principale breton l'avait
très très bien résumé tout ce qui est
interdit hors ligne doit être interdit
en ligne ça paraît vraiment de bon sens
c'est absolument le contraire qui se
passe aujourd'hui le rgpd n'avait rien
réglé le DSA ben on le voit maintenant
c'est il a été mis en place le mois
d'août s'est passé et aujourd'hui vous
avez vous-même tout à l'heure expliqué
ce ce qui se passe sur TikTok en prenant
en prenant un exemple on pourrait en
prendre des milliers ça ça ne fait que
se que que s'aggraver
euh alors voilà tout cela participe d'
d'une grande naïveté moi je voudrais je
pense que la question qui se pose c'est
la question que posa Lénine que faire
euh parce que la tâche est la tâche est
Viant par qu'elle est à l'extérieur elle
est à l'intérieur et on et on part avec
un handicap
considérable les les dictatures sont de
retour on les a cru mortes en 90 dans
les années 90 on avait cru que le 20e
siècle qui était le siècle la lutte à
mort entre les démocraties et les
dictatures sétait terminé par la par la
victoire des démocraties on s aujourdhui
que c'est pas vrai que c'est même le la
tendance inverse qui se passe et on en
est presque aujourd'hui à espérer et
d'ailleurs l'exemple de Rean que j'ai
pris tout à l'heure montre que le pire
n'est pas toujours sûr on est on en est
à espérer
que les dictatures elles-mêmes soient en
train de commettre des erreurs peut-être
pires que les NES la guerre en Ukraine
et pour Poutine qu'il la gagne ou qu'il
la perd une erreur considérable qui va
affaiblir le clan des dictatures la
situation en Chine on est en train de
s'en apercevoir et du point de vue
démographique économique et cetera
beaucoup moins bonne qu'on le penser
l'Iran est en proid voilà le le clan des
dictateurs s'est reformé mais en temps
le clan des dictateurs ne va pas
beaucoup mieux que le que les
démocraties je voudrais vous poser une
enfin une dernière question j'avais
présenter ici au Sénat un
amendement qui a été voté à l'unanimité
et qui disait
les schématiquement euh dans la querelle
sur dans la polémique sur les éditeurs
et les hébergeurs vous savez que les
plateformes disent nous ne sommes pas
des éditeurs nous sommes des hébergeurs
donc nous n'avons pas de responsabilité
euh le Sénat a voté cet amendement qui
disait en substance à partir du moment
où une plateforme trie l'information
qu'elle reçoit de ses abonnés par des
algorithmes elle a un statut d'éditeur
et non pas un statut d'hébergeur si vous
votez si si on vote cette loi ça veut
dire que les les les plateformes
deviennent responsables alors qu'elles
sont aujourd'hui irresponsables et que
toute la source du problème est là
évidemment euh cette cet amendement voté
à l'unanimité au Sénat n'a pas été
présenté à l'Assemblée nationale ne sera
pas présenté par le gouvernement je
voulais vous demander ce que vous pensez
de cela quand je dis que faire bien
entendu il y a beaucoup d'autres
questions si vous avez des réponses mais
sur ce sujet particulièrement j'aimerais
bien votre je suis désolé d'avoir été
beaucoup trop long non mais le propos
est intéressant ma liste de questions
s'est un petit peu agrandie je vais
peut-être donner la parole à Michel
Valley qui l'a demandé et qui est le
second rapporteur du rapport
TikTok
Michel bon
oui moi je suis corapporteur sur le
cyber mais je n'ai fait que présider la
commission d'enquête TikTok dans claude
miuré était et le rapporteur et
l'initiateur surtout et qui a suivi ça
c'est important que le lcon soit capté
parce que je commence par dire que
Claude maluré a cité lesénin ça restera
au contte-rendu des travaux du du
Sénat vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure le
parallèle avec avec les questions de
virus lorsque nous tomb dessus un virus
dont dont on ne on n'attendait pas
l'ampleur et auquel on nétait pas
préparé dans la vie quotidienne et bien
en très peu de temps on explique aux
gens et on fait de la pédagogie de
manière générale pour expliquer pourquoi
les masques pourquoi le contact comment
ça circule quels sont les bons gestes
barrières comment on s'organise pour
pouvoir sortir pas sortir et le message
passe puisque l'un dans l'autre d'un
point de vue de l'ordre public on peut
penser ce qu'on veut hein des mesures
qui ont été mises en œuvre mais en tout
cas elles ont été plus ou moins
respectées donc la pédagogie
et le premier élément essentiel vous
avez parlé de des États étrangers vous
avez parlé de la façon dont on
s'organise sur viginum le com cyber et
cetera vous avez répondu question que
j'avais sur viginum mais là se pose
aussi une question de très long terme
qui est celle de l'éducation ou on a
vite su tous parce que les biologistes
les épidémiologistes n ont expliqué
comment fonctionnait ce virus mais on ne
sait pas comment fonctionne notre
cerveau ou on le sait trop peu en terme
de vulgarisation scientifique ce sont
des choses qui passent à ses alors il y
a notamment des télévisions de service
public comme
Arté qui ont essayé de faire de la
pédagogie là-dessus avec des petites
capsules vidéo qui ont bien fonctionné
c'est un c'est une goutte d'eau dans
l'océan les questions de plasticité
cérébrale la façon dont nous réagissons
le fait que on a pu l'entendre dans des
auditions lors de la commission TikTok
même si vous êtes un peu outillé en
terme de raison de raison critique euh
une fausse information une première fois
vous arrivez à la une deuxième fois si
vous la prenez toute la journée 50 100
fois mécaniquement et de manière
scientifique par rapport aux questions
de plasticité cérébral que nous
expliquent les
neuroscientifiques ça finit par pénétrer
et on finit par se dire je résume il y a
pas de fumée sans feu il y a des
scientifiques qui travaillent très
sérieusement de manière mondiale sur des
des coortes avec du recul on les a
auditionné pendant la commission TikTok
en ce moment sur les infox et les
premiers résultats
montre que quand on explique à des
cordes
d'enfants dans un cadre éducatif à
l'école ou au collège que voilà ce que
c'est qu'une infox comment il faut
vérifier la source et cetera et bien un
des premiers effets constatés c'est
qu'ils en viennent à douter de
tout parce que quand on met en place des
mécanismes de défense on a cette
difficulté là donc ma question ma
première question la suivante est-ce que
un des enjeux au-delà des questions de
défense cyber la technique c'est pas
l'éducation et est-ce qu'on a les moyens
en termes financiers de mettre en œuvre
quasiment une nouvelle matière en terme
éducatif qui va au-delà de l'éducation
morale et civique et qui est vraiment
d'outiller nos citoyens pour les rendre
libres deuxème
question on peut parler des étrangers on
peut parler de notre naïveté mais déjà
avant d'aller sur les réseaux sociaux
n'a-t-on pas commis une erreur
fondamentale dans la façon dont nous
avons payé je veux dire pouvoir public
et l'État un réseau qui s'appelle la TNT
qui a introduit dans tous les foyers 18
20 ou 25 chaînes quand on en avait 5 ou
6 et où c'est une opinion personnelle
sera peut-être pas partagé par tout le
monde quand même quand vous zappez un
peu vous vous rendez compte ù vous avez
l'impression que la France est un
endroit où votre voisin est un criminel
en puissance puisque vous n'avez que des
documentaires sur les questions de crime
vous hésitez à sortir la rue dans dans
la rue l'été au Cap d'AC de ailleur
parce que vous avez avz constamment des
reportages sur la police municipale au
Cap d'AG ou que sais-je avec des trucs
complètement anxiogènes on a des
émissions de télévision où les gens s'en
mettent plein la figure en permanence
c'est ce sont des canaux publics c'est
que c'est nous qui devrions choisir à
qui on confie ça est-ce que dans notre
naïveté collective il y a pas aussi ce
premier sujet-l moi je vais citer
Poutine puisque Claude maluré cité
Lénine quelque chose qui n'est pas passé
à la télévision n'a pas existé et bien
nous si si on ne voit à la télévision
que des choses qui ne sont marginales
dans la vraie vie on finit par croire
qu'on vit tous dans un quartier où la
BAC intervient avec le voisin qui se
fait arnaquer merci Julien Courbet et le
le voisin enen face sur le palier qui
est un tueur en série en puissance et
qui pourtant était un voisin sans
histoire merci Monsieur les sénateur
pour pour vos questions s'agissant des
des premières qui qui m'ont été posé je
vais répondre à la question là plus
facile pour moi qui est la question euh
hébergeur ou éditeur pour moi comme
spécialiste de de la propagande il ne
fait aucun doute et spécialiste de la
propagande numérique il neffect aucun
doute qu' ne peuvent prétendre être des
hébergeurs ils sont des éditeurs à
partir du moment où il hiérarchisent le
contenu ou par exemple l'actuel
propriétaire de X Twitter a choisi de
baisser le nombre de personnes qui
pouvaient être touché par les
publications de New York Times et
augmenter de façon drastique le nombre
de personnes qui peuvent être touché par
des publications à caractère antisémite
donc nous somm en présence d'un choix
éditorial nous sommes en présence d'un
éditeur de contenu et devrait être
traité comme tel euh en ce qui concerne
ensuite ce que vous disiez de Ronald
Rean je voudrais juste quand même
rendre ce qui lui est dû au
renseignement
français qui en traitant une source en
Russie a permis à notre président d'Alor
François miteran de transmettre des
informations à Rean sur l'état réel de
l'économie russe qui ont pu
l'aider dans ses prises de décisions et
dans et dans et dans ses choix mais
plus plus fondamentalement ce à quoi
vous avez fait référence c'est c'est la
guerre cognitive c'est là nous disent de
façon très publique les dirigeants de
l'Armée populaire de libération de la
République populaire de Chine c'est là
que se trouve le le théâtre de combat
ultime des nations au 21e siècle à
l'intérieur même du cerveau
de nos concitoyens et c'est la raison
pour laquelle des investissements
considérables sont faits par ces acteurs
notamment par la Chine pour pénétrer
l'esprit de nos concitoyens vous citiez
TikTok bien évidemment qui est une porte
d'entrée à la fois majeure et
particulièrement inquiétante mais il y
en a d'autres un récent rapport publié
le 3 septembre me semble-t-il de
Microsoft indique que parmi tous les
influenceurs qui sont financés par le
ministère des Affaires étrangères nois
en Europe les plus nombreux sont les
Français et qu'en recrutant des
influenceurs français francophones il
s'agit aussi d'achever de réduire
l'influence de la France en Afrique dans
l'océan Indien il y a une entreprise de
déstabilisation à l'égard de notre pays
qui est manifeste et qui est même pas
dissimulé les toutes les doctrines
militaires de la Chine de la Russie sont
disponibles en ligne toutes les
adaptations qui sont faites aujourd'hui
par les doctrines militaires
occidentales cell du Pentagone il y a
quelques jours cell de l'an qui est en
train d'être d'évoluer sont également
disponibles et montrent qu'il y a une
prise de conscience mondiale de la
gravité inédite de l'intensité inédite
de la menace cognitive chinoise dans
toutes les dimensions s'agissant de
l'information oui monsieur le sénateur
je suis d'accord avec vous nous faisons
face à une infodémie et face à cette
infodémie il nous faut quelque part
sortir d'autres cloisonnements qui sont
là des cloisonnements universitaires et
scientifiques français dans mes
différents livres que je consacre à au
parcours de manipulateur de masse je
constate souvent qu'ils ont des parcours
qui sont inenvisageables en France ils
sont ils font de la physique nucléaire
et ensuite de l'informatique ù ils font
de l'informatique et de la psychanalyse
ou de la psychologie sociale ils font
ils font certaines disciplines qui
aujourd'hui en France sont très
dévalorisées comme la psychologie sont
des disciplines absolument cruciale et
centrale dans d'autres pays notamment
dans l'entourage de Monsieur zuckerber
il y a nombre de psychologues des
psychologues dont ceux que vous avez
auditionné sont régulièrement consultés
par telle ou telle plateforme pour les
aider à faire face à ce phénomène
d'infodémie donc il nous faut avoir une
approche globale aussi en terme
scientifique et acceptter de faire
discuter et dialoguer des scientifiques
qui n'ont pas l'habitude de dialoguer je
cache pas que pour ma part parmi les
scientifiques que je côtoie celui qui
m'apporte le plus c'est un mathématicien
David chavalarias qui a énormément de
talents et dont l'un des talents est de
rendre visible ces phénomènes qui sont
invisibles ces phénomènes d'interaction
sur les réseaux sociaux où il rend
visible c'est ce ce virus
informationnel sur sur Twitter en
particulier s'agissant de l'éducation
oui bien évidemment il faut éduquer
comme le fait taiïwan comme le font
nombre de pays comme le fait la Finlande
comme le fait la Suède il faut éduquer
nos enfants des plus jeunes âge non pas
tant à un scepticisme à l'égard de
l'information mais à une démarche
constructive qui consiste d'une part à
leur expliquer comment on construit
l'information comment on distingue le
vrai du faux et comment certains peuvent
chercher à affaiblir la distinction
entre le vrai du faux pour les tromper
une des démarches cognitivistes qui me
paraît la plus porteuse d'espoir
aujourd'hui et et celle d'un laboratoire
de l'université de Cambridge d'où sont
sortis certaines des innovations les
plus dommageables pour l'histoire de
l'humanité je parle de celles qui ont
été exploité par Cambridge Analytica et
par le renseignement militaire russe à
partir de 2014 euh donc dans un autre
laboratoire quelqu'un qui est du côté
clair de la force et donc du côté obscur
qui s'appelle Sander V Linden travaille
à l'élaboration de de vaccins
psychologique vous savez dans la dans
dans dans l'analyse traditionnelle de la
propagande il y avait ce que l'on
appelait à partir de 1937 la vaccine
vous allez euh atténuer une information
qui vous est dommageable en devançant en
quelque sorte l'arrivée de cette
information par un petit élément
d'information qui va atténuer la portée
de la même façon que c'est une souche
affaiblie du virus qui est à l'origine
du vaccin du vaccin traditionnel donc
une souche affaiblie de désinformation
pour renforcer le système immunitaire
des individus eux-mêmes face à
l'information nous en avons je crois
grand besoin et enfin
euh l'OCDE s'est emparé de ces questions
a créé un groupe expert
sur les manipulations de l'information
qui a tenu une première réunion publique
récemment l'OCDE a lancé aussi des
initiatives pour collecter les
initiatives prises par ces différents
États-membres qui ont porté des fruits
et le secrétaire général de l'OCDE a une
formule qui me semble tout à fait
pertinente pour nous indiquer ce que
pourrait être la direction vers laquelle
collectivement nous pourrions aller il
ue au free flow of information à la
libre circulation de l'information qui
était l'approche traditionnelle des
États-Unis depuis toujours le free flow
of trusted informations la libre
circulation d'information fiable ce vers
quoi nous devons tendre c'est une
réflexion collective sur le cadre et les
modalités d'une diffusion libre
d'information fiable pour répondre à
l'info d'émis par une diffusion aussi
que possible d'une information à même de
faire face à la défiance vous savez pour
terminer sur RT lorsqu'il y a eu
l'interdiction je fus l'un des rares à
parmi les chercheurs à m'exprimer
publiquement en faveur de cette
interdiction au nom de ce que j'appelais
l'état d'urgence informationnel c'était
un état d'urgence il fallait prendre des
mesures et cette mesure me paraissait
justifiée rétrospectivement le même
chercheur que je suis fait le constat
que cette mesure non seulement a été
sans effet puisque que l'interdiction de
RT ne s'est pas traduite par
l'interdiction des facto de l'accès à
ses contenus que ces contenus ont
continuer de circuler soit par le
recours à des VPN et aux consultations
sur le web soit par la diffusion massive
de ces contenus par des vidéos sur
YouTube et au passage permettez-moi de
relever le fait que s'agissant de RT le
modèle de diffusion privilégié à
l'échelle mondiale par sa sa rédactrice
en chef qu'on repose sur sur une
diffusion micro ciblée sur les médias
sociaux et non pas sur un nombre de
téléspectateurs devant le écran donc
l'interdiction de la chaîne sur l'écran
ne change pratiquement rien mais surtout
l'interdiction de RT je le constate à
chaque fois que je fais des conférences
publiques a eu pour effet de conforter
la défiance d'un grand nombre de nos
concitoyens d'encourager une défiance à
l'égard de ceux qui ont pris cette
mesure qui est interprétée comme une
mesure liberticide et qu'il est possible
d'expliquer mais ce qui est beaucoup
plus difficile c'est de faire face à
cette défiance tandis que lorsque ces
mêmes personnes y compris des gens qui
sont adeptes de de théories du complot
vraiment déconnecté de toute réalité
entendre un discours qui repose
sur les fondements même de notre
République la liberté à commencé par la
liberté d'expression la liberté
d'opinion la discussion est leur est
beaucoup moins favorable et sommes
toutes si quelqu'un veut chanter les
jouanges de Vladimir Poutine ou affirmer
que la terre est plate il en a le droit
ce qui est plus problématique pour nous
c'est lorsque ce discours est
artificiellement amplifié relayé porté
aussi par des agents d'influence
financés par le kremelin qui lui donnent
une place tout à fait disproportionnée
dans notre espace informationnel et euh
nos démocraties je pense ont les moyens
d'assumer leur force par la force de
leur liberté de leur modèle c'est ma
conviction de citoyen en même temps que
de
chercheurs merci je vous propose de
prendre en série les trois dernières
questions comme ça ce sera trois
réponses et votre conclusion si vous le
voulez bien monsieur le professeur la
parole est à Giselle Jourda merci
monsieur le Président alors non je
n'évoquerai pas les pays qui nous sont
chers au président et à moi-même à
savoir vous les avez évoqué euh la Chine
avec donc dont on minimiser euh l'impact
il y a
du Parti communiste chinois mais dont on
a vu le le le grand combat avec les
routes de la soie qui nous ont chè et
que nous avons particulièrement étudié
euh en revanche vous vous citez donc les
États-Unis vous citez la Chine vous
citer donc la Russie en ce qui concerne
la la Russie moi j'aimerais savoir si
vous avez une idée de l'ampleur de
l'implication de l'appareil
désinformationnel russe dans le conflit
actuel au prochouria
mais vous évoquez donc c'est États-Unis
donc Chine donc et Russie cuit de l'Inde
dans dans cette guerre don de
l'information dont vous dites qu'elle
n'a ni desb ni fin qu'elle est donc son
implication parce qu'on voit quand même
l'Inde en pointe sur dans beaucoup de
sujets que ce soit sur la stratégie du
spatial et cetera on la voit quand même
arrivver sur les marchés quel est votre
sentiment sur ce sujetlà et en et une
autre partie de ma question mais elle a
été vous y avez répondu puisque le le
monsieur le ministre maluré l'a
évoqué avait tras au propos de Thierry
Breton par rapport donc à la création de
d'un réseau donc BluSky don j'aurais
voulu connaître donc votre opinion sur
sa sur sa faisabilité pardon excusez ma
voix un peu un peu difficile
ensuite euh je finirai donc mon
questionnement
sur les propos donc et l'engagement de
notre du président de la République il a
fait donc de l'influence un objectif
stratégique de notre défense et sécurité
nationale il y a bien une prise de
conscience mais le problème est de
savoir avec quels outils une démocratie
peut s'engager dans une guerre de
l'information on a vu que nos médias RFI
ou France 24
d'être perçu comme des outils de notre
influence quelle méthode la France
peut-elle employer à votre
sentiment merci Giselle je passe la
parole à
Alain merci
Président je crois que dans il y a rien
de pire dans l'histoire que les trous de
mémoire on oppose toujours le bien et le
mal mais qu'est-ce que le bien et
qu'est-ce que le
mal il y a le problème de la parole
officielle souvenez-vous de la guerre du
golf où il y a une manipulation mondial
de de Coline paws de George buouch sur
les armes de destruction massive et
heureusement et là j'étais fier d'être
français de d'avoir un Premier ministre
Dominique de Villepin se faire quasiment
traiter de menteur par le reste du monde
entier donc la parole officielle elle
est importante mais euh faut-il défendre
on est toujours fort contre le faible et
faible contre le fort et là vous avez
parlé des printemps arabes cette guerre
2.0 mais les printemps arabes c'est le
résultat de la guerre du Golfe c'est
aussi le résultat de l'action française
quand on est allé chercher roménie en
Libye c'est le résultat de l'histoire
n'oublions pas tout ça
et la manipulation a toujours existé
souvenez-vous de du
présidentwood Wilson le Pacifique qui
s'est
servi de grandes personnes de la
communication comme Bernard bernes pour
faire changer l'opinion américain qui
était très pacifique et qui ne voulait
pas entrer dans la première guerre
mondiale et heureusement pour nous mais
la manipulation elle est partout et pour
terminé souvenez-vous la République
française elle vient d'une révolution
une révolution qui a commencé par par
des réseaux sociaux de l'époque qui
s'appelaient les libells et les libells
c'était nos grands écrivains comme
mIRABO au risque de leur vie qu'on
balancé dans la population parisienne
des des petites affiches pour réveiller
ceux qui ne savaient pas et grâce à ces
libelles grâce à ces petits réseaux
sociaux on a eu la Révolution française
on a eu la République
française une question alors non non
c'est l'avantage d'une audition comme
celle-là c'est un échange large Valérie
Boyet merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président je vais essayer
d'être bref parce que j'ai trois petites
questions à vous poser tout à l'heure
mes collègues ont évoqué
effectivement un réseau extrêmement
puissant qui a
déstabilisé euh nos démocraties et qui
était extrêmement bien organisé qui
continu à l'être c'est celui euh du
Parti communiste c'est vrai qu'il y
avait toutes les universités euh les
grands acteurs euh dont on célèbre
bientôt je crois qu'il y a un spectacle
à la gloire de l'un d'entre eux euh des
euh des journaux qui continuent à
exister euh où effectivement euh il
était difficile de de de résister à
cette propagande y compris même des des
petits journaux pour les enfants comme
Pif Gadget et aujourd'hui on a un petit
peu la même chose que avec le wisme et
vous n'avez pas évoquer cette ce
mouvement extrêmement
important où on assiste et c'est ma
première question aujourd'hui puisque
vous avez vu
que sur le plan économique le wisme est
sanctionné par les consommateurs si on
peut en juger par la déroute de de Walt
Disney qui revient sur sa politique
alors que en politique il est
imposé aux démocraties de façon parfois
très violente on voit ce qui se passe
aux États-Unis on voit même ce qui se
passe parfois chez nous également et
c'est ma première question pourquoi vous
n'avez pas évoqué le wid ma deuxième
question c'est que vous avez parlé de
l'influence bien évidemment euh et une
affaire qui moi m'a beaucoup secoué je
dois dire c'est c'est l'arrestation
d'une journaliste grecque et d'autres
personnes qui avaient subi l'influence
au niveau des européennes du Qatar et et
du Maroc et on a plus du tout entendu
parler de cette affaire mais on sait
bien qu'on a trouvé alors là c'était pas
des valises de Bignet mais des baignoirs
de billet chez ell et chez d'autres
justement pour qu'elle puisse pour
qu'elle puisse en tout cas c'est la
police belge qui avait trouvé ça pour
qu'elle puisse influencer de quelle
façon et ma troisième question pourquoi
on ne parle pas de ça parce que je pense
que c'est très important au niveau de
nos instances les influences via les
réseaux sociaux via des via aussi enfin
tout ça est très relayé et ma troisème
question vous avez parlé de
l'interdiction de RT ouais d'tacte
pourquoi on parle pas d'Al-Qaïda
aujourd'huialja et d'aljazira
excusez-moi quel lapsus
d'aljazira bien ben voilà Monsieur le
Professeur je vous propose de répondre à
cette dernière série de questions et de
nous livrer votre conclusion merci à
vous merci je vais vous répondre aussi
brièvement que possible d'abord en ce
qui concerne la Russie je répondrai par
la même occasion à la question qui porte
sur le wokisme la la Russie en réalité
euh depuis
euh très longtemps a constitué un un
réseau d'information vous faisiez
référence au mouvement de la liberté aux
interactions avec les partis communistes
à l'étranger du temps de la guerre
froide un réseau d'ONG un réseau
d'experts de soutien qui demeurent très
vivant aujourd'hui il y a de très
nombreux soutiens de la R aussi dans des
environnements français à à grande
échelle et pour le sujet qui est le mien
qui est celui des ingérances étrangère
je je ferais remarquer que il y a un axe
aujourd'hui de de désinformation qui est
un axe qui unit la Russie l'Iran la
Chine et leurs alliés respectifs Corée
du Nord la Syrie de Bachar
al-Assad le Hezbollah notamment et cet
axe est un axe contre factactuel
c'est-à-dire que c'est une grande
communauté
d'information contrefactuelle qui
s'emploie à diffuser des informations
pour contrer l'information officielle et
présenter une multitude de vérité
alternative sans toujours avoir de souci
de cohérence quant au récit alternatif
qui est construit c'estàd qu'il s'agit
davantage de déconstruire que de
construire un réel discours alternatif
et nous sommes ici en prence d'acteurs
qui s'emploie depuis longtemps à
instrumentaliser toutes les failles
préexistantes de nos sociétés et là où
des failles n'existait pas à en créer de
nouvelles et de mon point de vue la
question du voquisme s'inscrit dans
cette perspective c'est-à-dire que il y
a s'agissant de la Russie pour ne
prendre que cet exemple une stratégie de
long terme qui date déjà de la guerre
froide et consistante à instrumentaliser
les revendications des minorités quel
que soit le type de minorité en question
d'instrumentaliser toutes les
dénonciations des inégalités ou du
racisme par exemple dans les sociétés
occidentales pour
approfondir et creuser les les divisions
vous avait cité le Qatar il ne fait
aucun doute que le Qatar est aujourd'hui
un acteur majeur d'ingérence non
seulement en France mais dans de
nombreuses autres pays avec des relais
qui sont des relais parfois
extrêmement extrêmement
bruyant et je pense qu'une loi de
transparence en matière d'ingérence
étrangère comparable au pharas des
États-Unis serait de nature à nous
permettre d'avoir des faits sur
lesquelles s'appuyer si l'on pouvait
quantifier tout simplement cette
ingérence cela conduirait je crois à une
prise de conscience et peut-être la
mobilisation de certains esprits il est
important quand des gens s'expriment
notamment sur les chaînes de télévision
de savoir d'où ils parlent s'ils sont ou
non financés directement ou
indirectement qui par la Chine qui par
le Qatar qui par le
kremelin qui par un autre un autre État
s'agissant de l'Inde je ne me suis pas
effectivement focalisé sur cette
question dans la mesure où mon livre
traite de cette guerre de 30 ans entre
les démocraties et les régimes
autoritaire et en l'espèce il m'apparaît
que dans le domaine cybernétique l'unde
est d'abord l'endroit où l'on trouve
beaucoup de gens qui vendent des
services euh qui sont utilisés par les
uns et les autres aussi bien des
services de support informatique que des
services de trolling des services de
modération et je n'ai pas mais c'est
peut-être une faiblesse de ma part je
n'ai pas identifié de la part de l'Inde
de véléité agressive à l'égard de nos
démocraties occidentale vous avez
mentionné cet échange assez surréaliste
entre notre commissaire
européen Thierry Breton et Elon Musk sur
Twitter lorsque Monsieur breton
rappelait à Elon Musk qu'elle c'était
ses obligations au titre des règlements
européens et du DSA et que il a fini par
inviter les utilisateurs de Twitter
mécontent de Twitter à aller sur Blu Sky
qui est un réseau auquel on ne peut
accéder pour l'heure que sur invitation
et qui est effectivement un espèce de
paradis des journalistes et des experts
où vous ne risquez pas d'être trollé
d'être confronté à de l'agressivité à de
la désinformation ou à des bottes pas de
tout cas en de grande ampleur et il me
semble en l'occurrence
que Monsieur breton aurait pu faire
suivre sa déclaration des faits avec
l'ouver la création d'un serveur
européen accessible à tous financé sur
fonds public et qui nous permettrait de
mettre les esprits de nos enfants en
particulier à l'abri des ingérences
étrangères vous savez j'ai j'ai deux
deux filles à l'école elles sont toutes
petites la plus grande à 7 ans et à 7
ans la question qui commence à se poser
déjà est celle du téléphone portable et
sur les téléphones portables des plus
grands de CM1 et de CM2 qu'est-ce que
l'on voit on voit TikTok et sur les
écrans de TikTok qu'est-ce que l'on voit
on voit ce que Monsieur le Ministre
maluret évoquait tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire une volonté manifeste de
subvertir les esprits d'encourager la
violence d'exposer ses enfants à la
pornographie de les exposer à la
violence de les exposer à la propagande
de de de de fragiliser c'est
effectivement un enjeu sanitaire avant
d'être un enjeu un enjeu de de de de
souveraineté s'agissant de la remarque
que vous faisiez tout à l'heure s'agiss
à propos de la parole officielle il est
certain que le fait que nos démocraties
ait pu mentir et manipuler l'opinion
publique mondiale n'a pas rendu service
sur le long terme à nos démocraties les
États-Unis n'ont rien gagné à manipuler
l'opinion publique mondiale comme ils
l'ont fait en 2003 au moment de l'entrée
en guerre et cela doit être pour nous un
enseignement à savoir qu'une démocratie
ne doit pas mener des opérations de
manipulation de l'information ni
parrainer des opération de manipulation
de l'information et je me réjouis pour
ma part de de voir que la la France a
signé la déclaration mondiale pour
l'intégrité de
l'information qui a été lancée à l'ONU
en septembre dernier et qui fait
notamment obligation enfin dans lesquell
les pays signataires s'engagent à ne pas
mener de telles opérations de
manipulation de l'information parce que
vous savez j'ai parlé tout à l'heure de
la distinction entrem entre le vrai et
le faux et cette volonté des régimes
autoritaires d'affaiblir notre régime de
vérité et toute distinction entre le
vrai et les faux pour
conclure je voudrais
Infiné insister sur le fait que ce qui
est également en jeu ici c'est la
distinction
entre ce qu'est une démocratie et ce
qu'est un régime autoritaire si par
notre
réaction face aux manipulations de
l'information nous en venons
volontairement ou non à brouiller cette
distinction entre une démocratie et un
régime autoritaire nous ne ferons que
conforter en définitive les régimes
autoritaires qui attendent précisément
de nous cela ils attendent précisément
de nous que nous portions atteinte à
notre régime de liberté
ils attendent précisément de nous que
nous renforcions les la défiance à
l'égard des institutions publiques par
l'adoption de mesures contraignante ou
liberticide nous avons plus que jamais
besoin de nous défendre par notre modèle
et par la liberté et une dernière fois
je vous remercie infiniment d'avoir bien
voulu m'écouter aujourd'hui je suis très
heureux d'avoir participé à cette
audition bien monsieur le professeur
merci pard pard excusez-moi monsieur le
Président je voulais juste savoir quelle
était la différence pour Monsieur entre
RT et aljazira pour moi il me semble que
il n'y en a pas dans la mesure où
aljzira apparaît très clairement comme
un média d'État m'apparaît comme un
média d'État je peux me tromper
mais probablement pas comme un médiat de
service
public voilà qui est clair monsieur le
professeur merci d'avoir consacré
d'avoir consacré du
à notre à notre
commission juste deux
choses premier élément Jisel jourdda n'a
pas voulu l'évoquer tout à l'heure c'est
pas anecdotique vous avez évoqué les les
recrutements d'agents francophones par
les Chinois lors de notre premier
rapport sur les routes de la soie on a
fait un déplacement en Chine et nous
avons visité une université qui n'est
pas une université au sens où nous
l'entendons nous puisque il y a des
élèves qu' ont qu ou 5 ans et les plus
âgés sont en fin d'étude à 22 23 ans
avec cette particularité que tout se
faisait en français et en fait nous
avons rencontré de de jeunes enfants
classe de CP CE et cetera qui nous
récitaent des poèmes ou nous chantai des
petites chansons en français les plus
grands nous parlaient des matières
qu'ils étudiaient et effectivement les
étudiants qui étaient dans la
technologie dans l'ingénierie et cetera
nous exposer aussi le leur matière et en
fait quel était l'avenir de de de ces
coortes de de de de de jeunes en
formation bien pour les plus talentueux
c'était effectivement d'être affectés en
France et pour ceux qu'il étaient
peut-être un peu moins mais qui était
quand même bien formé c'était d'être les
encadrants chinois dans l'Afrique
francophone bien quand on imagine des
systèmes de formation comme ça c'est
quand même extrêmement impressionnant et
c'était en 2018 si ma mémoire si ma
mémoire est bonne la phrase d'un de ces
étudiants qui une de ces dernières
interventions a été mais comment se
peut-il que au niveau de l'information
on pu on puisse critiquer le pouvoir en
place dans les démocraties moi ça
m'avait énormément choqué donc voilà
c'est c'est pas totalement une anecdote
mais c'est un petit peu d'eau à à notre
à notre moulin collectif et pour pour
pour conclure donc vous remercier de de
de de de votre présence mes mes chers
collègues vous remerciez aussi de la
qualité de ces échanges vous avez pu
remarquer qu'on travaille ici dans le
temps long et effectivement le sujet qui
nous a préoccupé ce matin n'est
effectivement pas un sujet nouveau mais
je crois réellement qu'il s'accélère en
fait et les moyens technologiques qui se
développent et qui se développent et on
n probablement pas encore tout vu ne
vont faire qu'accélérer le le le le
problème moi ce que je retiens quand
même de ces échanges
c'est que quand on parle du bien et du
mal on est toujours sur une ligne de
crête et qu'il est extrêmement difficile
de de de de de de déterminer
effectivement en fonction des points de
vue des uns et des autres ce que peut
être le bien et le mal
et et la conséquence aussi parce que là
on est bien installé on a tous je crois
un certain niveau d'information mais
vous l'avez évoqué c'est qu'une fois
qu'on a tiré nos propres conclusions
comment les partageon
avec la population et comment peut-on
amener les gens à comprendre qu'à un
moment donné il faut bien réguler tout
cela sans que ce soit liberticide
c'était l'audition au Sénat du chercheur
David colon auteur du livre intitulé la
guerre de l'information un ouvrage qui
montre comment les états tente de
contrôler les opinions publiques en
manipulant l'information notamment
depuis le développement d'Internet voilà
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi continuez à suivre
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
sur notre site internet publsenna.fr je
vous souhaite une très bonne journée sur
Public
[Musique]
Sénat